مساء الاعلام الاسرائيليه في هذه الاثناء
تقول بان منفذ عمليه اطلاق النار في سلوان
بالقدس يبلغ من العمر 13 عاما
دل على شيء فهو يدل على مقدار
الغضب والقهر الذي يصيب الفلسطينيين وربما
رغده كل اا يعني انسان يطيح له فرصه الرعب
لكي يرد احيانا في عمليات انفعاليه
ولا اعتقد ان احدا يغير ذلك هؤلاء اطفال
يجب ان يكونوا على مقاعد الدراسه
مره اخرى كما طرحت عليك قبل قليل
ان كانت الامور تتجه الى مرحله جديده من
الصراع مرحله جديده من المقاومه يعني
بالنظر الى اعمار منفذي العمليات اليوم
نتحدث عن طفل ثالث عشر من عمره عمليه
الامس كانت شاب همم يبلغ من العمر يعني 21
عاما
ان لاحظي ان العمليات يعني اشد تجري في
القدس يعني في الموقع الذي تسيطر فيه
السلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بشكل مطلق
ولا نفوذه للسلطه الفلسطينيه
نعم الامور يمكن ان تندفع الى مرحله جديده
من التصعيد الشامل ما لم تتدخل القوه
الدوليه للاسف الشديد العالم المنافق ساره
الى التمديد بالعمليات الفلسطينيه وتبنى
الروايه